so we have two inequalities here the
first one says that X plus 2 is less
than or equal to 2x and this one over
here in guess this light purple move
color is 3 X plus 4 is greater than 5 X
now over here we have four numbers and
what I want to do in this video is test
whether any of these four numbers
satisfy either of these inequalities so
I encourage you to pause this video and
try these numbers out does zero satisfy
this inequality does it satisfy this one
does 1 satisfy this one does it satisfy
that one so I encourage you to try these
four numbers out on these two
inequalities so assuming you have tried
that so let's work through this together
so let's say so if we try out if we try
out zero on this inequality right over
here let's substitute let's substitute X
with zero so we'll have zero plus two
needs to be less than or equal to two
times zero is that true well on the left
hand side the sieve is two needs to be
less than or equal to zero is that true
is 2 less than or equal to zero no 2 is
larger than zero so this is not going to
be true so this does not satisfy this
does not satisfy the left hand side
inequality let's see if it satisfies the
right hand side inequality or this
inequality right over here so we in
order to satisfy three times zero plus
four needs to be greater than five times
zero well 3 times zero is just zero five
times zero zero so for needs to be
greater than zero which is true so it
does it does satisfy they'll write this
inequality right over here so zero is
does satisfy this inequality now let's
try out one let's try out one so to
satisfy this one one plus two needs to
be less than or equal to 2 C 1 plus 2 is
3 is 3 less than or equal to two no
three is larger than do so this does not
satisfy the left-hand inequality what
about the
right hand inequality right over here so
3 times 1 plus 4 needs to be greater
than 5 times 1 so 3 times 1 is 3 plus 4
so 7 it needs to be greater than 5 well
that's true so both 0 & 1 satisfy 3x
plus 4 is greater than 5x neither of
them satisfy X plus 2 is less than or
equal to 2x now let's go to the 2 I know
my it's getting a little bit unaligned
but I'll just do it all in the same
color so you can tell so let's try it 2
here so two plus two needs to be less
than or equal to 2 times 2 so 4 needs to
be less than or equal to 4
well 4 is equal to 4 and it just has to
be less than or equal so this satisfies
this satisfies the left this inequality
what about the right what about this
purple inequality let's see 3 times 2
plus 4 needs to be greater than 5 times
2 so 3 times 2 is 6 plus 4 is 10 needs
to be greater than 10 10 is equal to 10
it's not greater than 10 so it does not
satisfy it does not satisfy this
inequality if this was a greater than or
equal to then this would have been a
greater than or equal to and it would
have satisfied it but it's not 10 is not
greater than 10 its greater it's it
would satisfy greater than or equal to
because 10 is equal to 10 so 2 satisfies
the left hand 1 but not the right hand 1
all right let's try out 5 so 5 over here
five plus two needs to be less than or
equal to 2 times 5 once again everywhere
we see an X we replace it with a 5 so 7
needs to be less than or equal to 10
which is absolutely true 7 is less than
10 so it satisfies less than or equal to
so 5 satisfies this inequality and what
you're probably noticing now is that an
inequality can have many numbers that
satisfy it in fact they often haven't
they sometimes will have nothing that
satisfies it and sometimes they might
have an infinite number of numbers that
satisfy it and you see that right over
here we're
testing out a few numbers and for this
left one zero and one didn't work 2 & 5
did work now this right one zero and one
worked two didn't work let's see what
five does so in order for five to
satisfy three times X now X is we're
going to try out for five we're going to
try X being five three times five plus
four needs to be greater than five times
five three times five is fifteen fifteen
plus four is 19 19 is to be greater than
25 it is not so five does not satisfy
this inequality right over here so
anyway hopefully you found that fun